it's come to this because
the court has not listened to britney
spears
and what she's shared with them we heard
today
in her own words at her request that
this was made
public because actually at the beginning
of today's hearing
there was a motion made to keep
everything closed
but brittany herself said no she wanted
the public
to hear what she had to say in 2019
she went before this judge in a closed
hearing and
told this judge that she didn't not want
to be in the conservatorship anymore
and she's had to endure another two
years of this she's called this
traumatic she says that she cries every
day
and that has been forced to do things
against her will
like performing while sick not being
granted a break
being forced to go from one vegas
residency to another
and just sounding just
completely like a like a broken woman
but defiant at the same time
um you've not always been complimentary
about it have you perry's i mean we have
to put that out there
looking back how do you feel about some
of the things you said about her
and whether or not it contributed
potentially to her mental health
challenges
yeah you know i take full accountability
for how i behave in the past i can't say
oh i was just
young and dumb i think
we know a lot more and initially
many folks myself included were shocked
and alarmed and especially concerned
for her young children and i know that i
did not express myself as well as i
could have i didn't lead
with empathy and compassion which
thankfully it seems like most people now
are understanding the severity of
brittany's situation but i absolutely
apologize
and carry just deep shame and regret
um how do you feel towards her father
um in 2008
i am many others thought that
jamie spears saved his daughter i
i was really worried that had this
conservatorship not been put in place
that britney could have ended up dead we
forget
but she was really putting herself in
dangerous situations
almost every single day going out in the
city
by herself without a security team
ending up in a hotel
talking to strangers it was a very scary
time
so i think you know we often hear
where's the family why isn't anybody
stepping up and helping out
well her dad did and as brittany herself
said
in court on wednesday
that old expression money is the root of
all evil
for 13 years now she says her entire
family has been living off of her and
this conservatorship and
what may have started off with good
intentions has
become corrupt over the years so do you
think that it was the right thing to do
back in 2008 but it's just gone on for
too long is that what you're saying
well i used to think it was the right
thing to do
because that's what we were told we were
told that britney was in such
poor shape but recently the new york
times the paper of record
shared with the world that when
britney's father
filed the paperwork to put her under a
conservatorship
that he checked off dementia
after hearing her speak today
clearly i'm not a doctor or a medical
expert
it's dubious that she has
dementia so i have to now question
everything over the last 13 years
brittany also said that you know she
didn't know that she could
end the conservatorship by just putting
in a request
so hopefully you know there's another
hearing scheduled for next month
uh hopefully it's the positive hearing
with a positive update that
you know brittany can finally be free
like she wants
and then what and then what for her do
you think
well brittany said that she wants to get
married and wants to have another child
but she does not have say over her
own body the conservatorship doesn't
just control her finances
it controls her medication and clearly
forcing her to have contraception
uh you know hopefully nothing bad
happens
after whenever if she hopefully
is no longer in the conservatorship but
the overwhelming majority of people who
have
who suffer from severe mental health
issues are not
in conservatorships so why should
britney spears be in one
is it just because of money and then i
think of the question of free will
you know if britney wants to spend all
of her money
gamble it do whatever she wants with it
shouldn't
she be able to she also brought up the
question
or the subject of manner many of money
many times during her court appearance
on wednesday
i just want to ask you before i let you
go um you you've you know full some
apology for things that you've said
about her in the past
if you could sit down and chat to her
now over tea or whatever what would you
say
i well i emailed i emailed britney a
letter
last year and i apologized
privately as well as publicly but i
would just want to hug her
i just want to hug her i'm vaccinated
and
i i think she is too from what i've seen
on social media she shared that she got
at least
one dose i think she just needs love
because i cannot imagine the betrayal
and the sadness and the emptiness that
she must feel
believing and knowing and experiencing
this total lack of just
not support and not being there for her
from her entire
family her mother her father her brother
her sister
it's soul crushing